Oprah said she asked God for a sign on
whether or not she should run for
president but she hasn't had a sign yet
yeah yeah then someone pointed out Trump
being president is the sign
we're in good shape okay
today First Lady Melania Trump said she
is proud of the administration's opioid
program yeah very proud of the opioid
program yeah money is added for example
I haven't felt a thing since January
through that Walmart's in the news
yesterday Walmart announced that they
will not sell guns to people under 21
yeah yeah Walmart added but if you're 22
and pissed off come on down
it's a bit of a bummer but I had to do
it
Starbucks Starbucks has opened a new
store that serves alcohol yeah
Starbucks said the biggest challenge was
figuring out a way to burn wine clearly
that's that's my more my pet peeve than
anybody else
oh it's mine too yeah yeah they burn the
out of that coffee
korie's with me on that one right Cory
you big coffee drinker Cory no how is
that helping me out Cory simple yeah
sure mr. O'Bryan sure yeah yeah that's
all I wanted yeah Cory Conan likes lies
yeah
KFC you like KFC Cory
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I like Cory yeah wrong camera
all right anyway let's try it again huh
[Music]
[Applause]
that guy goes to sleep all right here we
go
KFC announced it is running out of gravy
yeah yeah when they heard this people in
Wisconsin rushed to the local Red Cross
to donate there's a new dating app by
the way I just want to say when I on
that did this set up to that joke and
said KFC is running out
this audience freaked out I mean nothing
else the fights had a comment was headed
towards Earth you'll be like all right
we'll see what happens KFC is running on
what eight eight people are gone I know
they left there's a new dating app out
there I've heard that there's a new
dating app where you can try to find
someone compatible by giving a sample of
your DNA yeah which is weird because I
thought exchange in DNA was supposed to
happen
at the end of the day
by the way if you're curious that's
Cory's mom Hawaii also matches before
the show why would you take him to such
a filthy program this is your idea good
good wayward youth all right here we go
you